mark I feel like the best analogy I can
make is you had this amazing last minute
and 12 seconds of the last movie but I
feel like in general with the last movie
you were a member of the team but you
were kind of sitting on the bench right
what did you do to make sure that you
were going to be able to rise to the
occasion as much as you did with your
role in this fantastic film a minute and
12 seconds was force awakens yeah Wow
seems like twice that long yeah well I
was really intimidated because first of
all I never expected to come back who
knew there was a Jedi pension plan but
I'm a big fan of Ryan's work and you
just don't get those kind of
opportunities the idea of returning to a
character all those years later and then
to find out differ the character was
from what I remember because in the
first three pictures Luke always changed
from an innocent farm boy the young
trainee and then eventually a Jedi so I
have a beginning a middle and an end and
I thought that's fine I'm ready to move
on but what a great opportunity to come
back was a thrill Ryan a very simple
straightforward question how did you get
this job such you're just such a great
job on this was it a case of you through
your team fighting for it was it
Kathleen Kennedy the people at Lucasfilm
seeing looper maybe and thinking you
were right how did it all come about no
I I never would have even imagined that
I should spend the energy fighting for
something Li I mean I would have thought
why waste my time that never imagined
that was on the kind of in you know in
the running for anything like this
reiver would be it was it came kintyre
Li out of the blue and it was entirely
from Kathy Kennedy she called me in I
had met her a few times before just
general meetings and then she called me
in for what I thought was another
general meeting and she shut the door
behind me and just asked me point-blank
if I would be interested in doing this
it was completely a surprise to me and I
don't really remember the rest of
that meaning but boy I yeah I mean I've
had the time of my life making this film
I we're for whatever bizarre reason she
decided to ask I'm very happy that that
she did I'm very grateful and my
understanding ROM is that you guys were
really given free reign by Cathy Kennedy
and Lucasfilm to take this story the way
you wanted it and really make it your
own
what if any marching orders did you get
from the mothership as far as crafting
it or or kind of furthering the story
that they already had in mind I don't
think they got Ryan got Denny marching
orders when Ryan started writing the
script
they just started filming episode 7 so
everybody was so busy in filming by the
time that Ryan finished the draft they
it was just like a month after they
finished filming and you know he
delivered the script and everybody loved
the script and that's it so that once
everybody responded to the script
they're kind of like ok trusted Ryan and
let him do his thing but I should I
should add that during the process it
wasn't like I went away and vanished and
then came back and dropped a script and
I'm I didn't want it to be that that
seemed terrifying to me and so while I
was breaking the story I moved up to San
Francisco for a few months and that
would go in twice a week to sit down
with the folks at Lucasfilm and just
they have it like a creative group of
folks that work there and I would just
kind of spill my guts out and tell them
what I was working on at that week and I
just wanted to keep them part of the
process so that at every stage
especially as I was as the story was
taking me to some places where I'm like
is this is a little different than what
we probably expect and this is not going
to pay off the way that you would
automatically expect it would can I do
this that and the main danger was made
kind of self editing and they they
weren't really policing me they were
more often than not giving me permission
to challenge things and to and to find
the most interesting path forward even
if it's not necessarily the safest path
Michael of course I have to ask you as
the costume designer about the casino
scene I want a whole movie that just
takes play
amongst those people and the the looks
there were just so fabulous what were
you going for with that sequence and all
those costumes to be perfectly honest
when I when I read the screenplay I
thought that maybe I was reading a James
Bond movie and I was a little bit
intimidated or in doubt that I could
kind of translate this into the world of
Star Wars
it was quite daunting and the size of it
there were there were over 200 extras
each one dressed uniquely and we've been
used to doing large numbers of costumes
but generally for uniforms so we make
one of every uniform in-house and then
we multiply them at a uniform makers
place this was in-house bringing in
milliner's bringing in jewelry makers
every single thing on every extra an
actor in that scene was manufactured at
Pinewood Studios
it was like working at MGM in the 1930s
again you also cast every extra I did
varium Michael got very involved on
design level and finding faces finding
interesting bodies and then on set
Michael was constantly attached to my
shoulder as I was directing saying are
you getting green frame are you getting
in there and he would be like have you
seen her yet he was making sure he was
making the Jamaican and that I loved
that was that was such a gift to have
someone who was so invested and it was
it really was because I thought I'd
never ever work again
Matthew the the sequences that I was
really struck by sonically are the
conversations between Daisy Ridley and
Adam driver through space and worse
connections what you do with the with
sound effects with their dialogue
especially in this amazing theater was
so cool
yeah our sound designer we have a new
sound designer coming to Star Wars here
his first film red clay
he works with david fincher a lot
fantastic collaborator and work that was
one of the early sequences that we were
trying to get right you know reading in
the script you can see that it's gonna
be sound related there's gonna be themes
that need to change there's going to be
visuals that there that are gonna have
to be pretty fantastic so the sounds
gonna have to go with that and so as a
proving ground really early on
Bob do say Ren and the editor and and
our department went in and we made those
sequences pretty early on and we were
able to keep them in the avid and
actually work with them and test them
out and internally with ourselves but it
was more about bringing focus into each
scene just we had you would have like
breath maybe a footstep here and there
and then obviously we have the mirror
cave sequence which is a whole other a
moment where there's a lot of pre delay
and reverb coming in so it's it's almost
like these characters are being
connected across the universe and their
lines are coming from you know it's like
when someone says Luke you know and I
would any take Luke under the screen as
we reverse reverb it and bring it back
so it's we wanted to have a sense of its
transportation across the universe but
by being connected you know by Snoke and
so there was just a lot of those kind of
early things we worked on and we and we
do them in the avid which was great so
we could we could keep them and keep
temping them and been working on them
and so we get to the final mix it's not
a big surprise that's always fun cuz we
come on to the show pretty early so we
can work out a lot of this sound pretty
early that's kind of a Lucasfilm thing
there's been great George used to have
us come to the sets really early and
Kathy Kennedy has extended that on so we
got to come in and see the design scape
go to the sets you know pick up and hold
up org in our hand and then see the game
you know the weapons and the costumes
and everything so that's just that's
really inspirational it's kind of a
thing that Kathy's extended on from the
way we used to make films with George
that's been really fun Ryan when you
were working on this film my
understanding is that in your mind
this was the one movie you were gonna do
this was your one and done Star Wars
experience and now it's been announced
in the last couple of months that you're
going to direct for this first film in
this new Star Wars trilogy are you happy
that you didn't know
that you were gonna do more orgy would
you have liked that kind of feeling in
your mind knowing that this was not
gonna be your one shot at one of these
films oh I don't know that's an
interesting question I mean the the I'd
it definitely was something that we were
getting towards the end of making this
movie and had just had such a good time
with obviously with the cast and crew
but more so with Kathy and with the
folks at Disney we had such a good
working relationship we were all it felt
like we were it was the last week of
senior year we were all cleaning out our
lockers and all getting kind of sad and
saying how do we keep working together
and you know it was it was that and
that's when I said you know the most
interesting thing to me would be to come
up with a full story to hold over three
movies and tell a new Star Wars story go
new places meet some new folks and I
forget what's that going to be called
now I actually don't know yet that's the
thing I'm at the beginning of the
because that was the entire pitch it's
not like I said and it'll be this my
pitch was let's do a new Star Wars
trilogy and tell a new story and Kathy
was like that's exciting let's do it so
I'm just at the very start of coming up
with what that's what that's gonna three
well fantastic mark as we see in the
film the special connection between Luke
and Leia and when you think back over 40
years what would you say Carrie Fisher
means to you in in your life
impossible to verbalize I met her when
she was 19
within 20 minutes she was telling me
intimate details of her parents divorce
and I was like should I be hearing this
she could make you feel like the most
important person in the world and much
like real siblings we had our ups and
downs I mean she was a handful and but
so funny
and what was great about being able to
do this film was that what I came out to
the studio and I wasn't shooting whether
it was doing wardrobe with Michael or
stunts with CC I make a beeline to her
trailer because it was impossible not to
have fun around this woman
hard you know I think I'm still in
denial I did watch the scene and it just
took me completely out of the movie
it'll take me a while you know I can't I
just can't
but she's so wonderful in the movie and
you know instead of being really angry
that she's not here I should be grateful
for the what who 41 years that I did
know her guys thank you so much and
congratulations